[Music]
we were really trying to increase the
efficiency by which a report is
generated from what surgical
pathologists do on a day-to-day basis
which is look at tissue sections under a
microscope and render diagnosis after
examination and studies we're four
students at MIT MBA MBA and then two PhD
students and we've been working on a
project to rethink the process of sine
out in the pathology department and
facilitate the transition to a paperless
diagnosis of entry system we've been
thinking about overall workflows kind of
who's doing what during the day to the
granularity of like how the monitor is
set up in the booth we did a lot of
observation from the transcriptionist at
6:30 in the morning to the flight
technicians in the gross description at
7 o'clock at night and really seeing
that full workflow of what's happening
every day do you feel like overall
typing versus handwriting when you're
doing slide preview do you think it's
better worse I think it's actually much
easier to type it by having the H lab
come in and work with us and having a
fresh set of eyes from the outside
because we're biased we're in the system
we're biased it's great to have that set
of eyes because they will say well yes
if we change one thing it could change
for other things and so we're trying to
anticipate what might happen
I talked with one of the members of the
staff she told me like all these
experience would be better for the
residence if we had two screens and I
was looking at the offices I mean there
are some of us that you clearly like the
way they're set up like you cannot put
it easily in the second screen but in
that case we are proposing a change and
we're proposing a change that will
impact all the doctors basically day to
day life and there are some people
who've been working here for 30 years in
their own way and they have already
figured out the best kind of the most
efficient way for them and we want to
bring technology to make their life a
lot more efficient but suggesting this
change and expecting this change to be
accepted by doctors who are used to
their own way of doing is very
challenging
one of the themes that we've really seen
from our interview so far is there's a
fear of the documentation burden being
shifted to physicians and that's
something you know changes course
difficult and people have a lot of
anxiety about some of the changes we're
talking about in terms of paperless
implementation we're putting out a
survey to the staff
how many minutes a day do you spend with
just IT issues we can implement all of
this and if we don't have the
infrastructure to support what we're
trying to do then it's meaningless we
have observed and we'll be very honest
here with the frustrations and
skepticism around paperless initiatives
when we ask different doctors like oh
how do you go about asking for new
devices when the systems are very
antiquated almost all the doctors had
very different responses and that was
very surprising to me because in fact in
an any Enterprise IT support system
should be like everyone should have a
single kind of email or hotline that
they can reach out to one of the
frustrations that a lot of pathologists
have including myself at times is when
you go to partners ID you get a ticket
you way they come and they rebuild your
computer that's their solution if we're
really pushing that we move to a
paperless system this IT support system
cannot provide a good foundation to
allow our doctors to be successful in
this system
the student team built a simulation
model to then show the leadership here
the different changes and what the
effects would be and where they should
start from an implementation standpoint
in the simulation model the way this
works is we have cases arriving
according to a process that's based on
the data you go from accession to gross
examination then the case splits for
slide processing and coalition and
continues through as it gets to certain
steps and they're no resources available
it ends up waiting in a queue there are
different ways you can choose to
allocate resources may be changing the
shifts schedule changing the way that
you have the slide technicians at
certain times versus transcription is or
how long can you let the QA review go
before it becomes a bottleneck types of
questions like that we think could be
answered with this model we knew where
we wanted to get we just didn't know how
to get there they pointed out the
challenges the things we need to do to
help overcome those obstacles and then
gave us phases in which to implement
this program using these tools they now
have the data in order to affect change
within their own organization so it
gives them credibility amongst their
peers and with their leadership in order
to improve the system the final product
is really amazing it's something that
you can do something with there's a set
of practical solutions there's such a
proposed timeline for implementation the
project itself actually told you how to
interact with the organization get your
hands dirty and see how things are
working on a date
databases at the end of the class you
definitely realized the system is as
complex and probably more complex than
if you thought it was when you went in
but you also see that there really are
so many opportunities to improve the
system and there are so many people from
industry from academic settings who are
really like committed to making those
change so there's no shortage of ideas
and there's no shortage of I and it's
just a matter of getting it done I
learned many things from my colleagues I
learned from my teachers and learned
from my holes I learned from everybody
and I hope that others have also learned
something from myself so this exchange
of knowledge exchange of experiences
being a journey that we really see
ourselves growing over time as as people
as professionals as human beings
you